right let's begin our afternoon session
our next speaker needs no introduction
for many years he has been dazzling us
with beautiful ideas and insights coming
from quantum field theory that have kept
several generations of mathematicians
busy and more recently with his coursers
he found the links between the language
program and dualities in quantum physics
so it's a great pleasure to have ever
waiting from instead of anesthetic we'll
talk about mirror symmetry and geometric
langlands thanks for the kind
introduction and I guess I can thank the
organizers for inviting me since I'm not
one so I want to start by explaining why
it's natural to associate geometric
langlands to a quantum field theory
specifically in four dimensions so also
I want to say I know the audience is
very diverse so there will be
occasionally some big words thrown in
that will make more sense to some than
others you're supposed to ignore them
when they come along so geometric
langlands involve statements about a
Riemann surface see which for us is
simply a two manifold but the basic
statements are not statements about
numbers or vector spaces they're
statements about something more abstract
called categories and here we have to
remember what quantum field theory does
a d-dimensional quantum field theory
associates to a closed D manifold M sub
D a number the partition function it
associates to a closed D minus 1
manifold MD minus 1 a vector space which
is the space of physical States and to a
D minus 2 manifold it Associates a
category which you can think of as a
category of boundary conditions for
practitioners of quantum field theory
and for dimensions the first two steps
in this hierarchy are familiar and the
third one is slightly less familiar
where physicists have used the third
step in the hierarchy most is for D
equals two where in string theory one
has brain
which arises boundary conditions in
quantum theory and although this isn't
the language physicists usually use
mathematicians speak of a category of
brains and that's a special case of the
fact that in general and d dimensions
quantum field theory attaches a category
of boundary conditions to a closed d- 2
manifold now in geometric langlands
we're supposed to have a category 2 a 2
manifold so we want the u minus 2 to be
2 and a small amount of arithmetic
reveals the d should be 4 so to make a
statement with the general nature that
we have in geometric Langlands we should
start in four dimensions now what kind
of quantum field theory are we going to
do in four dimensions well all the
particle physicists will tell you that
the interesting ones are gauge threes
those are roughly speaking the only
quantum field theories that really work
in four dimensions but there's another
reason we should start with gauge
theories well first of all another I'll
give you another naive reason before I
go to the reason in the next page which
is more technical another naive reason
is that geometric Langlands involve
statements about groups and although
it's not quite the only way the groups
come into quantum field theory gauge
groups are conspicuous a conspicuous way
for groups to enter now if you want to
say something more technical so
geometric Langlands involve statements
about roughly speaking the moduli space
but really the stack of g bundles or the
analogous type of flat bundles for the
dual grip on the two manifold c since
we'll be doing gauge Theory so here I
differ from the notation most often used
in geometric langlands G is a compact
lee group which will be the gauge group
of our theory and when I'm I'm
interested in its complexification I say
so so this symbol denotes the
complexification of G so where would
stacks come in to quantum field theory
what do physicists know do which is all
about stacks without saying so well as
explained 30 years ago by TN bud in a
paper that Nigel mentioned in last talk
the natural field theory
of the stack of old bundles it's just
the space of all gauge fields active and
by the gauge group in other words well
to be technical you fix a G bundle over
at C remembers our Riemann surface you
fix the G bundle E over C of a fixed top
of a given topological type and you
consider all possible connections on
that bundle so that's a model if the
stack of GC bundles the reason is the
following on a riemann surface as
opposed to a variety of higher dimension
every connection defines a whole morphic
structure that's because we take any
connection and just as in I think
Nigel's talk we write it as the sum of
parts of 0 1 and 1 0 but on a riemann
surface the 0 1 part always squares to 0
because there isn't any room for a 0 2
part dimensionally so every connection
in dallas are bundled with a holomorphic
structure and having a homomorphic
bundle of the given topological type
arises this way so in fact the quotient
of the space of connections by the group
of complex valued gauge transformations
is the set of ice and morphism classes
of GC bundles and you can think of the
pair the space of connections with an
action of the gauge group as being a
model for the stack bungee I should
maybe just say one thing which is that
even though our connections are unitary
the complexified group acts on this base
of connections that's because we
transform novel 0 1 by a complex valued
gauge transformation but the overall
connection is supposed to be real
but novel 1 0 is just the complex
conjugate of novel 0 1 so we make the
complex conjugate transformation of
novel 1 0 so it's not a symmetry of
gauge theory but it's a operation that
makes sense on the space of connections
so in a sense this is more natural than
any customary model any customary
description of the stack of G bundles
there isn't any nice
I don't know whether there's a finite
dimensional model for the sack of G
bungles but there is presumably not a
canonical one year at the cost of going
to infinite dimensions there's a
completely canonical model for the sack
of G bundles as the quotient of this
infinite dimensional space by the
infinite dimensional gauge group now in
to do geometric Langlands we're supposed
to well the point is there's going to be
differential graded stuff so in
particular there's a differential which
for us is a symmetry or square zero but
it's a fermionic symmetry it Maps even
stuff to odd stuff and vice versa so a
field theory that's going to have odd
symmetries as a supersymmetric field
theory so our four-dimensional theory
which is going to be a gauge theory
because that's what there is in four
dimensions and also because it's
supposed to involve gauge groups is
going to be a supersymmetric one so
being a supersymmetric one it has got a
bunch of odd symmetries and one of these
odd symmetries will be the differential
of geometric Langlands so what super
symmetric gauge Theory ever going to do
well first question you might ask is
what ones are there and physicists know
about that because that's a decent chunk
of what we study so one simple thing I
can tell you is that for every G there's
a maximal supersymmetric gauge Theory
one that has the most possible symmetry
and that turns out to be the right one
for geometric Langlands so it's called N
equals 4 super yang-mills theory so this
theory is determined by the choice of a
compact simple e group J as well as a
complex parameter which is called the
coupling parameter that takes values in
the upper half plane so it's got all
kinds of fascinating mathematical and
physical properties this theory for
example well ok I won't mention I'll
limit myself to the examples that are on
the slides so also it's determined by
the choice of a gauge group and also a
coupling parameter but there's a
classical equivalence which is related
to the integrality of the set
turn class if I explain if I were to
explain exactly how one constructs this
theory forgiving towel then you'd see
that because the second turn class is in
integer class that results in a
periodicity undertale' going to tell
oppose one but there's something much
more interesting which is a quantum
equivalence that's Montone and olive
duality orresto allottee or electric
magnetic duality those are some of the
names it goes by that exchanges G with
jeetil where aji dolor G check is the
Langlands or Godard noise Olive dual
group in this audience most of you know
how Langlands introduced the dual group
and later on I'll recall how God anoints
and olive did and n G is an integer
that's the ratio of length squared of
long and short roots so it's one two or
three depending on G and finally so just
like the G Theory has a tail parameter
the G check theory has a tail check
parameter so tail check is the coupling
parameter of the N equals four theory
with the dual gauge group and the theory
with the dual gauge group also has an
integer value and second turn class so
it has a classical symmetry that shifts
talib by one so there's an infinite
discrete group that acts on the tail
plane or the qaol dual plane now for us
the real star of the show is the quantum
duality symmetry that exchanges the
group with the dual group and also
exchanges the two coupling parameters so
it's called electric mechanic duality it
exchanges ordinary electrically charged
particles with magnetic monopoles and
it's extremely important in modern
theoretical physics for example it's
related to the mechanism for confinement
of quarks in atomic nuclei and it's a
prototype the existence of this duality
symmetry in this gauge theory is a
prototype for the modern understanding
of the strong coupling pager of string
theory
now comparing to geometric Langlands
there's a perfect symmetry between three
descriptions one description uses J is
constructed from J and the other
description is constructed from G vowel
and the two theories are constructed in
exactly the same way so there's a
perfect parallelism between the two
sides people who work in Langlands
correspondence will not by other methods
will not expect this because the usual
formulation is very asymmetrical between
G and jiggle the correspondence is often
called a duality but it's a duality
between one construction from G and a
quite different looking construction
from G goal whereas here at the
fundamental level we have a complete
completely parallel construction and the
fundamental duality symmetry merely
exchanges the two groups and while
inverting the coupling parameter there
so question you might ask me is if this
is the duality that underlies geometric
langlands why does it look asymmetrical
well I'll go in more detail later but
the reason is that you ask a question
that breaks the symmetry between the two
sides but I thought I would tell you
that it's not only in math that the
symmetry sometimes lost it's also
physics in practice not usually as
perfect as the mathematical model on
describing so perhaps the most important
application of this general circle of
ideas in physics is two quark
confinement but that actually is an
example somewhat like other approaches
to Langlands there are two different
dual descriptions one good for one class
of questions and one better for
different class of questions there but
there's not a simple symmetry between
the two descriptions so in that sense
there will the real-world problem of
quark confinement is much more similar
to other approaches to the Langlands
correspondence then the highly idealized
mathematical model I'll be telling you
about today
well as I've already alerted you it's
the electric magnetic duality symmetry
that exchanges the two groups that leads
to geometric Langlands duality so that's
actually as a physicists I claim that
that's geometric langlands duality while
standing on one foot of course just the
hard part is to spell it out and explain
precisely what questions you ask where
when you work out this duality in
practice you arrive at the traditional
statements such as we've heard in
previous lectures now the usual
geometric langlands correspondence
actually involves questions that don't
depend on towel or towel duel so in that
context you can think of the duality as
merely exchanging the two groups there
is a generalization of geometric
Langlands that people sometimes call
quantum geometric langlands I'm not a
fan of the name because to me the whole
theory is best studied in the context of
quantum field theory but anyway there's
a generalization that people call
quantum geometric langlands that does
depend on the two taylor parameters and
then the infinite discrete duality group
is important but we won't be discussing
this generalization today so as I said
before from this point of view the basic
formulation is completely symmetrical
between the two groups
but the symmetry will be broken by the
choice of questions so I mean there are
all kinds of things that I should tell
you about N equals 4 super yang-mills
theory and it really should follow a
couple of courses on quantum field
theory but one thing which is so basic I
should have mentioned it is that this
theory is conformally invariant so that
means that to formulate it on a four
manifold m4 we require only a conformal
structure as well as a spin structure
not a romanian metric now on four
dimensional Minkowski space-time so that
means that so any well the usual quantum
field theory studied in particle physics
are naturally formulated in Minkowski
space-time and then they are invariant
under the motions of Minkowski
space-time that
serve its pseudo-riemannian metric but
here we thought a conformally invariant
theory so it's invariant under a larger
group of conformal motions in four
dimensions the group of conformal
motions is so2 4 but to allow for spin
we take its double cover which is su 2 2
however we're dealing with a super
symmetric theory so it's a lot of
morphisms will not just be su tu tu but
a super group that extends this and for
N equals 4 super yang-mills this super
group is the simple super group PSU to
2/4 so I mean roughly speaking that you
could think low except for the P you
could think of that as a a space of
autumn matrices that act on a space of
dimension 4 / 4 with 4 dimensional even
rank in four-dimensional odd rank the
off diagonal blocks are the odd
generators of the super group so the
diagonal box or the maximal bosonic
super group which is su 2 comma 2 x su 4
so su 2 2 is the conformal group of
space-time but su 4 x trivially on
space-time so what is su for what fizzes
is called a group of our symmetries but
that's just a name for mathematicians
I'll give you an example of a group of
our symmetries so when a Kahler manifold
there's a su 2 symmetry of left shifts
that acts on the ecology of a Kahler
manifold well it's usually called SL 2
if you think of the Kahler manifold as
just a well in a world where you would
deal with harmonic forms the group that
acts naturally on the harmonic forms is
su 2 the real compact real form of so2
anyway in this line of work the theory
of differential forms on the manifold is
a one-dimensional quantum field theory
where the one dimension is time usually
suppressed in the mathematical treatment
and the group of symmetries that acts
trivially on the time is the left shits
so2
on a hyper counter manifold left shits
sl2 is extended to an SP for that acts
on the co homology of a hyper kellerman
holder and that's still one dimensional
quantum field theory here we're in four
dimensional quantum field theory so
things are a little bit richer and
instead of being SL 2 or SP for the
group of our symmetries is actually su 4
now p su to 2/4 might seem like a rather
big super group but it's just barely big
enough that you can fit geometric
langlands in there so I said at the
beginning that we were discussing the
essentially unique theory supersymmetric
gauge 3 with gauge group G with the
largest possible supersymmetry algebra
we could use a smaller supersymmetry
algebra for example if we wanted to head
for Donaldson Theory instead of
geometric Langlands but geometric
langlands barely fits in this theory it
doesn't fit in the smaller ones so so
there's a procedure which I won't
explain in detail of twisting a physical
theory to make a topological field
theory and we make use of some of the
bosonic symmetries in the twisting but
we're left over with something so one
thing we're left over with is a
particular odd generator and also a
particularly even generator both the
even generator as part of the our
symmetry group so the odd generator
becomes the differential of geometric
langlands and the even generator gives
us a Z graded Theory so actually the Z
grading comes from a subgroup of the SU
for our symmetry group that was also
true for left shirts of course the left
shits oh sorry it's not true for left
shirts so I better not there's a YouTube
that acts on the ecology of Kaling
manifold perhaps if we go to the hyper
killer case the assertion dice bonded
into would be correct
I think it's SP 4 rather than SP 4 times
u1 that acts on the ecology and then the
grading by degree is part of the our
symmetry group so in general
N equals 4 super yang-mills is
definitely not a topological field
theory I mean most physicists who study
it are not thinking about topological
field theory at all by far
I mean well over 99% of the literature
on this theory does not deal with
topological field theory so it's a
theory of physical propagating fields
but you can get a topological field
theory by picking an odd generator Q of
P su to 2/4 chosen to the Q squared is 0
after which roughly speaking you pass
through the ecology of Q or more exactly
you think of Q as a differential in
constructing a differential graded
Theory so they're in equivalent choices
of Q and so there are several different
topological field theories you can make
so you have to pick Q so that the
response of the theory to a change in
the conformal structure is Q exact so I
won't try to explain what that condition
means in practice but there are three
and equivalent ways to achieve it
they're all interesting for example one
was thought one of the three was studied
by Vava and me and we showed that a
generating function for oil are
characteristics of instant-on moduli
spaces was going to be a modular form
and another of the three theories leads
to geometric Langlands so it's the
choice of q that broke the symmetry
between G and the door group
now I can't possibly explain everything
today but I want to give a few hints and
the best way to give ants I could think
of was to tell you what are the fields
on the theory and what is the condition
for a set of fields to be Q invariant
which is you should think of it as being
a semi classical approximation to
computing something like describing an
object in a category calculating a space
of morphisms or doing something for
physicists finding a space of physical
States the approximation is to find a
classical state that's Q invariant so
what are the relevant fields were in the
description by the dual group the
relevant fields are a complex value
connection it's very important that this
is complex we started with the compact
gauge group but by the time we twist in
the GEVO description we end up with a
complex valued connection on a bundle
whose structure group is the complex the
gauge group and it comes together with
an end a morphism I wrote endomorphism
of am but that should have been
endomorphism of the bundle II understood
to be in coma magical degree - in other
words under the C grading which came
from a distinguished so2 in the R
symmetry group it has degree 2 and for Q
invariants they have to obey some
equations which say that the curvature
should vanish and the end of morphism
which should have been Sigma V u is
currently constant so the classical
picture is a flat bundle together with
the symmetry of it
if the bundles irreducible then the
endomorphism will have to be zero
so that's a situation that's often
considered roughly speaking on a
sufficiently rich form a default of
generic flat bundle will have no nonzero
and morphisms so often in practice Sigma
will be zero so this was the description
in terms of the dual group in the
description by J the fields are
connection a on a G bundle here there's
no complexification the structure group
is the compact form and also a feel of
Phi which is one form valued in the
adjoint bundle it's actually the same
structure that Hitchin talked about in
his last lecture except that we're in
four dimensions instead of two so we'll
get a more complicated set of equations
but they can be specialized to the
equations Hitchin told you about so they
buy a system of different lipsticks
differential equations so what I'm
writing down is the condition for Q
invariants the condition for set of
fields to be invariant under the
differential that we use in different
geometric Langlands is that the fields
have to obey a set of elliptic
differential equations elliptic means
elliptic modular with the gauge group
and star is the odd star operator in
four dimensions so there's also an end
of morphism sigma of degree two in this
description that's now related to a
quivering comala G so an approximation
to what you do is that you study some
kind of cone ology of the space of
solutions of these equations except okay
if the gauge group acts freely you could
adorn Sigma but when there are solutions
that don't completely break the gauge
symmetry you should better do
equivariance kamala g rather than
ordinary comala G and then Sigma can
come into play so one thing which
actually it's a fun story but we don't
have time to go in that direction today
is that these same equations I'm talking
about here are also important for a
certain description of the Jones
polynomial and covent ophthalmology
using gauge theory in fact using
basically the same gates three
ingredients that lead to this story
involving geometric Langlands
so these equations are also closely
related to Hitchens equations and Higgs
bungles and that's how the IG's bundles
will make an appearance so the quickest
way to say that is that if you look for
a solution of these equations those are
equations let's say on our 4 you could
pick a projection of our 4 to our 2 and
ask for a solution that's a pullback and
then you'll get Hitchens equations so
Hitchens equations are the two
dimensional specialization of those
equations in that sense now as I've
already remarked in geometric Langlands
we're going to study the category of
boundary conditions the boundary of the
four manifold is going to be a three
manifold what geometric langlands is
usually formulated for a time
independent situation which means that
well one of our coordinates will be our
space time will be the product of our
parameterizing the time time something
and in particular the boundary will be
the product of the time our times of
riemann surface c c is the riemann
surface in which we do geometric
langlands so i've drawn your a picture
with the time suppressed this is a
picture at fixed time i've simply tried
to draw a three-month-old whose boundary
is a given riemann surface so we're
interested in the category of boundary
conditions so let's discuss some
boundary conditions well in the g dual
description which deals with flat g dual
bundles an obvious cycle boundary
condition is to simply specify a flat G
dual bundle on the boundary and require
that the boundary values of the fields
coincide with that flat bundle so an
example of a boundary condition is to
pick what people in geometric Langlands
call a G dual local system a flat bundle
on C whose structure group is G Bo
subsea except people and geometric
langlands would usually call it just G
dual because they wouldn't have started
with the compact group so these boundary
can say traditional D rachet boundary
conditions or at least the simplest ones
would say that the fields are zero on
the boundary here that would correspond
to a boundary condition associated to
the trivial local system instead of
saying the flu so even in elementary
textbooks on analysis instead of taking
a bowl toss equation with zero boundary
conditions you can take the Laplace
equation with any specified function and
look for solutions of La Paz equation
with that function on the boundary so
that's the kind of shifted or twisted
version of d'Orsay boundary conditions
here we twist by specifying a flat
bundle on the boundary and asking that
the fields coincide with that flat
bundle it's less obvious what our
natural boundary conditions in the G
description or how to compute the dual
of a given local system of the door
group it's actually very powerful to
first understand what happens if we
split off not just one factor of R but
two factors of R so we take our four
manifold to be the riemann surface see
that we're interested in times r2 so you
can think of that as being merely that
we take this picture but far away from
the boundary
I drew C times what might have been R
plus 1/2 line if we're far away from the
boundary it just looks like C times R
but I've suppressed the time and drawing
this picture so it would really be C
times R 2 so C times R 2 just means
we're trying to understand what happens
far away from the boundary and then
we'll come in toward the boundary so the
sentence I just displayed is what I just
said we first discuss what happens far
away from the boundary and then we it'll
be easier to understand held the duality
acts on boundary conditions on R so I
mean asking what happens on R 2 times C
it's the typical kind of problem that
physicists study actually so we
compactify it
well we compactify on CEO we turn on the
magnetic field or we do something and
then we ask what happens at long
distances
so on our two times see the theory is
described at long distances that means
on a length scale large compared to the
size of C by a conformally invariant
theory on the r2 lots of highly
non-trivial statements because generic
quantum field theories aren't
conformally invariant conformally
invariant ones are very special and
often very important in this case we get
conformal invariants back at long
distances because there's still a lot of
supersymmetry
even after compacta fiying 1c so the
theory is what physicists call a sigma
model a supersymmetric theory of maps
from r2 to what I'll call em s of H of C
and G that's hitchens hyper killer
modify space of G bundles on C so well
okay this statement is true for both
groups regardless of whether the group
was G or G dual we get that appropriate
Hitchin moduli space so the same and
I've just made was first shown by
physicists in the 90s and then the
mirror symmetry that I'll mention in a
second was first discussed by house'll
and Thaddeus know among other things
we're giving a very simple example of
earlier ideas most Rominger yellen's a
slow but the rough idea is that so if
you're far from the boundary so I mean
if you're physicists the one important
question to ask is what happens all the
length scale large compared to the size
of C in geometric langlands there's no
length scale so but what that means is
that you're always a lengths large
compared to the size of C but when you
formulate it as a physicist starting
from the physical problem you do have to
explain that you're going to long
distances and then at long distances you
almost have a you basically have a
solution that's almost a pullback from C
and the solutions that are pullbacks
from C are the solutions of hitchens
equations as he described them in the
last lecture before lunch
so anyway that's an intuitive idea of
this assertion that the longest since
approximation is a signal model whose
target is the Hitchin moduli space now
the Hitchin moduli space for both jng
duel both have Hitchin vibrations and
the base of the h and vibration is the
same for the group on the dual group
according to Strom injury on Saslow
mirror symmetry is t-duality on the
fibers of a vibration a special
Lagrangian vibration which usually is
difficult to exhibit explicitly but the
point of the paper of house'll and
Thaddeus in part was that in this case
well it has to do with what you also
heard in the last lecture that there are
many different complex structures going
on at once the whole picture is a little
bit too complicated to explain right now
but the h n vibration which is a
holomorphic vibration in one complex
structure from a different point of view
is a special lagrangian fibration so we
can understand mirror symmetry much more
explicitly than we usually do by
t-duality on the fibers of the Hitchin
vibration and i'm roughly speaking
geometric Langlands duality is the
mirror symmetry between the B model of
one modify space and the a model for the
dual group so the claim is that s tality
in four dimensions simply reduces in two
dimensions to the mirror symmetry
between these two models the reason I
said roughly speaking is that although
this description captures a lot it
doesn't it's not precise enough for all
the delicate questions that are usually
asked in geometric Langlands
now there's another important part of
the story that was which I won't explain
today I'm just stating it on this page
and edy Frankel stated it toward the end
of his talk so so I gave a simple
example of the Deedle boundary condition
it corresponds to picking a local system
but a local system is just a point in
the h and moduli space so our simple
example on the what's sometimes called
the Galois side of the geometric
langlands correspondence was to pick a
GU local system which means a point in
Hitchens moduli space when we make
t-duality on the fibers of niche in
vibration a point is mapped to off the
whole fiber that contains it endowed
with a flat line bundle that depends on
which point you started with I showed
him that a picture I should have made
this into a slide that I didn't so here
I'll just very briefly sketch the hitch
in fibration
and now we've picked a point of or over
it in the G little description in the GE
description we have an a different
vibration over the same base but
importantly it's over the same base so
the tool of that point is the whole
fiber here but which point it was goes
into what flatline bundle this fiber is
endowed with so we appoint is mapped to
an a brain that's supported on a fiber
of the engine vibration so at least at
the simplest level that's the answer to
the question what's the dual of a be
brain supported at a point however I did
not get the answer in the language that
people like in usual approaches to
geometric Langlands I expressed the
answer as an a brain and instead we want
a demodulate Frankl kind of loosely
indicated because of the close relation
of niche and modify space to the
cotangent bundle of Bungie in this
situation a brains have an alternative
interpretation as d modules and
that leads to the usual formulation of
geometric Langlands well there's another
thing which we really should try to say
at least a few words about so the point
of all story in blancmange
correspondence is to show that the dual
of a be brain supported at a point is a
key eigen chief so I'll kind of tell you
what that's true without quite telling
you what it meant
assuming that various bits of what I'll
say will be understandable to different
people so the key point is something
that actually is quite important in
physics the duality between Wilson the
tough line operators or in other words
between parallel transport in jiyul
gauge theory and a singularity of a
certain type in a G gauge field so all
i've drawn in this picture is a curve it
could be a closed curve or maybe it ends
on the boundary we don't usually want it
to end in the interior of the manifold
but i've just found a piece of a curve
in a four manifold without on this page
telling you what we're going to do with
it now on the next page i'll tell you
two things that we could do I think it's
the next page what you're going to be
dual to each other we can do one of two
things in the dual gauge Theory we pick
a representation of the dual group and
then well the way methergine say it is
that we take the bundle associated to
Edel in that representation and that
gives us a jeetil bundle over m and then
we perform parallel transport if we have
if we have a section of that bundle
restricted to the line and we can
parallel transport using the connection
restricted to L so when you do that in
the context of quantum theory it's
called a Wilson operator and the
physical interpretation is that L is the
world line the world line means the path
in space-time followed by a point
particle so a point particle is a point
at a given time but in space-time its
trajectory will be a van a curve
the world line so the physical
interpretation is that L is the world
line of a charged particle in the
representation in a chosen
representation of the gauge group so we
decided what was going to be the world
line of this particle that means it's
not one of the particle is described by
the theory it's an extra particle that
we added as an impurity so I claim that
I claimed at the beginning that there's
a complete estou ality between the g
goal and g descriptions so anything that
we can think of in one description has
to have a dual in the other description
so in this case the dual of parallel
transport is known
it's the enough to operator and it's
definition is rather interesting in GE
gauge theory well you have to remember
that we're in four dimensions so if you
have a in three dimensions if you think
of this piece of chalk as a line it's
linked with the a circle around it s1
but in four dimensions the link of a
curve would be a copy of the two sphere
so we're going to specify a singularity
that a GE gauge field should have along
L and we'll specify it by saying that if
you take a very small two sphere no
matter how small I'm going to specify
what the gauge shows look like 1s2 in in
a moment and that will define a
singularity because the choice I'll make
will be one that won't extend over the
interior
if you remove L from space-time then
I'll just explain what a gauge field
should look like but it will be singular
along L because it'll have a curvature
integrated over s2 which doesn't go to
zero when s to shrinks so well what are
we going to do well s to first of all as
a cop is there's a conformal structure
on space-time so s2 has a conformal
structure so it's actually a complex
riemann surface CP 1 and as I told you
before every gee bungle describes a g
sub c bungle a whole morph abuse of c
bungle and the adult operator is defined
by specifying the holomorphic type of
this bundle
the physical interpretation is that the
singularity represents a magnetic
impurity of specified charge the charge
is the Hall morphic type of the bundle
so in the Langlands correspondence an
important fact well an important fact is
that representations of the dual group
correspond in a natural way
so I some morphism classes of G bundles
over CP one it's not always stated that
way but G bundles over CP one can be
classified and if you use that
classification you'll end up if you're
not accustomed to stating the line ones
correspondence this way you'll find that
if you use the classification of bundles
on CP one you'll probably end up with
the version of the statement that you
are accustomed to as a statements about
electromagnetic charges in
four-dimensional gauge theory the
statement that the dual of a of parallel
transport into giving representation is
given by this other singularity goes
back to Godard noise and olive although
it was clarified much more recently by
kapustin so now remember in geometric
Langlands the dual of a local system is
supposed to be a Hecky eigen chief and
without explaining all that all the
details I'll say the thank you and chief
property comes from the duality between
the two types of line operator in the
situation depicted okay in the situation
where L is near the boundary I've
suppressed time in this picture so you
imagine that I sketched a three manifold
with a point in it you take the product
of that times time so I've drawn a lousy
points but it really is a line running
in the time direction and see in the
parallel transport description what we
would have at this point L is just the
fibre at that point of The Associated
bundle to the to the given
representation of the dual group what in
the G representation
we'd be insisting on a funny singularity
and that funny singularity will cause
the gauge field along C to undergo a key
modification when you jump past the
singularity so since I've lectured about
this many times before and some of you
have heard it and time is running short
under there's a lot to do I won't
explain details but you could take the
gauge fields here they would jump so you
could take a copy of C at the boundary
but you can take a copy of C at some
place else and as you move in toward the
boundary when you cross the singularity
the holomorphic there's a jumping of
holomorphic structure which gives what
people in geometric Langlands regard as
the geometric analogs of Hecky
modifications when I was interested in
trying to interpret in terms of quantum
field theory geometric langlands well
there are plenty of things I've never
managed to do and they're still
completely unclear but among things that
eventually became clear the hardest one
for me to understand at least was the
fact that geometric Hecky operators
simply corresponds what physicists call
atrophic operators so a be brain
supported at a given local system is an
eigen brain well I didn't know what the
right word is here that's why their
question marks they're not typos in
geometric Langlands an eigen chief has
an eigen value which is a vector space
so here the eigen value eigen space is a
vector space by which the brain will be
10 surd if you introduce a charged
particle at the point L and Uli the a
brain will be a key eigen chief that's a
general prediction of the duality and in
terms of a brains you can verify it
fairly explicitly using standard
properties of the interent fibration
rather than explaining all this in more
detail I want to describe an approach in
this framework to the universal kernel
of geometric Langlands and here I'm
following ideas explained in my paper of
a few years ago with lava to Kyoto
so we're going to divide so we're going
to describe the universal kernel in a
universal sense so what is the universal
kernel as understood conventionally you
fix the Riemann surface see and you want
a procedure that will transform any
shape in the dual gauge group into an
object in the gauge group J so in our
language of B brains and a brains you
want the universal mapping from B brains
to a brains but as usually formulated
the notion of the universal kernel
you're allowed to pick a Riemann surface
C but we're actually going to be more
Universal we won't pick C we just divide
space-time into two halves so I'm not
much of an artist but this picture
represents our four old Minkowski space
r31 but I've divided it on a co
dimension one plane which you can think
of as r2 1 and I do gauge 3 with gauge
group G and uncoupling parameter tau I
hope that looks like a towel but since
there is a duality I could explicitly
use a dual set of variables over here
which are these the dual group and also
the dual coupling parameter but if I
literally do that would have trouble
saying anything because you see remember
the dual coupling parameter is minus 1
over the dual parameter and together
simple semi-classical description which
one should aim for if one wants to be
able to make concrete statements you
want em tell an Intel dual to be large
but they can't simultaneously be large
if they obey that relationship so that's
actually what makes geometric Langlands
and the quantum field theory duality
that we're talking about today both
difficult and interesting however you
can modify the problem you can verify
tell and tell dual independently of the
cost of reducing PSU to 2/4 to a sub
group the largest sub group you can
retain is actually I OSP 4/4
a maximal bosonic subgroup of which is
SP four times so4 where SP four is the
group of conformal motions that fixes
the plane if all we did was to make
duality on half of the variables it's
just a change of notation and we haven't
broken any symmetries but when we vary
the the parameter is independently on
the two sides we're really changing the
problem and we're only left with
conformal motions that Li fix the plane
in which the jump occurred so we only
see three-dimensional conformal
symmetries and a smaller are symmetry
group so if we take the imaginary part
of both talento tool very very large the
gauge groups are weakly coupled and semi
classical and the subtlety all resides
at the interface supported at this
interface is a three-dimensional super
conformal field theory this is the
second time third time I've told you
about a super conformal field theory
today we started with one in four
dimensions we've reduced one a Riemann
surface and got one in two dimensions
and we now are putting in this domain
wall between two different descriptions
and finding a super conformal field
theory now in three dimensions but this
super conformal field theory has a
symmetry which is the product of the
symmetry of the dual group times the
symmetry of G the way physicists would
say it is that G fuel gauge fields on
the left and G gauge fields on the right
have been weakly coupled to a super
conformal field theory of the interface
between them so guy ought to and I
called this theory T of J so you can
object that our nation is slightly
asymmetrical because we could have
called a T of jeetil that's right it's
something I think I'll second okay
anyway since it'll be a while I'll just
say now that there's a mirror symmetry
between T of G and T of G tool so
although my notation is asymmetrical
there's actually a non-trivial
automorphism that restores the symmetry
now
since I describe TFG in a slightly
abstract way which might have sounded
like all I was saying was that well if
there is a duality we must be able to do
something so abstract but you see there
was a non-trivial statement which was
that when both Tallinn tell duel went to
the semi-classical region we were left
with the superconn form will feel very
own interface and that statement has a
lot of information so I want to make you
make it sounds a little bit more
concrete so I'm going to tell you the
most interesting things I could think of
to tell you about TFG inside two minutes
so one thing is that TFG for groups of
type a can be constructed as a quiver
gauge theory so I'm hoping a lot of you
at least know what aquiver is so these
are circles and this is a square sorry
for the poor drawing this is a circle
here so then that's a very particular
linear quiver there and so in the math
literature there's really a lot of work
on hyper Kahler manifolds associated to
quavers perhaps starting with chrono
moreau Nakajima but for physicists you
can construct from a quiver not just eye
not just a hyper Keller manifold but a
super conformal field theory in three
dimensions which among many other things
has got a second type of killer manifold
associated to it and
one of the important things to tell you
about would be the moduli space and
let's turn this off okay one of the
important things to tell you about would
be the moduli space vacuole of the
theory but maybe first I'll tell you
briefly about mirror symmetry in three
dimensions which has been explored by
both mathematicians and physicists and
the papers I've indicated plus a lot
more physics papers so in this case so
to appreciate better what I'm going to
say one should know something that not
very many methods are familiar with
about mirror symmetry in two dimensions
which is its relation to an outer
automorphism of the super conformal
group I'm afraid there isn't really time
to explain it but there's a similar
story in three dimensions where the our
symmetry group so4 has an outer
automorphism that comes from a
reflection of one of the four
coordinates and this is actually an
outer extends to an outer automorphism
of OS p 4/4 so so4 is actually locally a
product of two su two groups on the
outer automorphism exchanges them so
finally I'll say that in this context
mirror symmetry exchanges gng dual while
also exchanging the two su twos so in
other words the mirror of T of G is T of
jeetil and one of the su twos is going
to be the RSL - although which it is
depends on our choice of differential
and the way we broke the symmetry
between G and jiggle so the moduli space
of a Q of the theory is going to be a
conical hyper killer manifold with an
action of a lot of stuff the group and
the dual group act and so did the two su
twos and unfortunately here it's
important to know a bunch of things that
we don't have much time for so many
naturally occurring objects that are
often regarded as complex symplectic
manifolds with a seastar action that
rescale the symplectic form
are actually also naturally study does
hyper killer manifolds in fact Nigel
Hitchin when somebody done but the line
toward explaining this in his last talk
although we didn't go to precisely this
so for the hyper killer manifold C star
which is U 1 times the positive reals
because is extended to su 2 times the
positive reals where su 2 rotates the
complex structures so if you pick a
complex structure and you're only
interested in that one rather than the
hyper killer structure then you only
would see the subgroup of su 2 that
fixes a particular complex structure and
that's u 1 so from a hyper killer point
of view the group that acts is actually
the quarter nians if you think about it
su 2 times the positive reals is the
group of nonzero quaternions but from a
complex point of view the group that
acts as the non zero complex numbers so
there are a lot of examples of this but
the example is important to us are do to
cry no more then open and orbits in the
layout of a complex simply group and
also the corresponding slot away slices
all have this kind of hyper colorimetric
with an action of the invertible
quaternions with this understood so now
when i refer to an orbit I really mean
an orbit in this hyper Kahler sense with
the so the moduli space of vacuo ft of j
is naturally embedded in the product of
the two null two nilpotent cones of the
two Leo Chavez where on the note put in
cone of G dual there of course acts
doodle and also an su 2 group that I'll
call su 2 X and on an the Maps G
together with the other as you do
so and as many strata the top strata are
what physicists call Coulomb and Higgs
branches they are one cone times the
origin and the other cone and vice versa
flowers drought our products of orbits
where the orbits are certain nil put in
orbits in the tule Ottawa's so for
simplicity I'll just draw the picture
for a one for a one there are no lower
strata and the moduli space of acura is
just the union of two nilpotent cones
intersecting at the origin so you can
ask what this sort of description of the
universal kernel of geometric Langlands
is good for well I don't I certainly
don't completely know but I'll just make
a couple of remarks that I easily can
make one is that if we add a description
of T of J in which if we could calculate
explicitly and see all the symmetries
that would be an explicit answer for
geometric Langlands duality that
statement there probably means that what
is asserted in that sentence is out of
reach at any rate in the descriptions I
know it's very hard to see explicitly
the full G check times G symmetry you
can see a symmetry of G times the
maximal torus in T in G check in g2 or
vice-versa and using this you can use
the theory T of G to compute the dual of
a local system whose structure group
reduces to the torus you can do some
more general things but that's an
example of what you can do and you got
something like the geometric Eisenstein
series of baruman and gates gray so you
could think of this as a quantum field
theories way to motivate the
construction of something like geometric
eisenstein series I haven't thought
about it carefully but it's plausible
you could do the reverse use a knowledge
of the G dual times T action to get the
restriction to bunty of the D modular
for bungie correspond to any local
system of the dual group
now taking the liberty to perhaps go
over time just a few minutes I want to
add a few to say a little about how
Arthur's sl2 crimson so let's go back to
the classical equations in terms of the
dual group which were that we had a flat
bungle with a covariantly constant
endomorphism so far we discussed the
obvious sort of boundary conditions in
which we specified the boundary values
of the fields but the equations actually
admit solutions with a pole along the
boundary and these solutions were
important in my work with Gatto so but
that's kind of why I thought that
they're worth telling you about so well
let Y be a real function that's positive
way from the boundary and vanishes on
the boundary so n is defined by Y being
non negative and by a pole I mean that
near y equals 0 Sigma looks like B over
Y will be as a fixed element of valley
algebra
well if this is going to happen B has to
be no Potence and the reason it does is
that Sigma Sigma dual is currently
constant so it's characteristic class is
independent of Y but if B has a nonzero
eigen value of that eigen value is
scaled when we change Y and the
characteristic class of Sigma would
depends on Y so the only way for
something a function like this to have a
cut conjugacy class independent of Y is
that B has to be no opponent and
conversely one B is no opponent you can
see that you can solve these equations
with such a Sigma provided the
connection based appropriately near the
boundary so I think we can interpret B
as being in some sense the open and
raising operator of Arthur's sl2 but I
don't know the most general statement so
I'll tell you something I'm a little bit
more sure of which is also closer to
what Guyot so and I were doing so well
specialize to the case where m is a 3
amount of fall times R plus so at some
points in lecture the 3 manifold was
time times C
but if we do that we do lose something
we fail to see that the theory is a
topological field 3 but factoring all
Elfi r+ doesn't lose anything that I can
see that that we need to understand to
understand the category of brains and
the usual story of geometric langlands
of course we do lose the interpretation
in four dimensional topological field 3
1 we do specialize the Romani and
Holland Rumi of M becomes smaller and
therefore the twisting procedure which
involved embedding the Romani Halle Nomi
of em in the our symmetry group leaves a
larger unbroken subgroup so so because
one previously we embedded so4 in su for
in such a way that the community was so2
which led to the z grading of geometric
Langlands but now we're only going to
embed so3 and su for and the communists
will be not so2 but su 2 so the so2 that
gives the z grading of geometric
Langlands is extended to su 2 and in
fact this is the su 2 X or AZ u 2 y that
we discussed before which it is depends
on what we picked for the nilpotent
generator kill that we use to make a
topological field 3 now once you've
split off a normal direction from the
free manifold you can extend this
complex endomorphism sigma to a triple
of endomorphisms the transform of the
adjoint representation of the combined
group su 2 x times the dual gauge group
and I claim that ask you to extra the
identified as Oh Arthur as SL 2 in fact
one can define a natural boundary
condition in the doodle description for
every time a morphism
of Pi 1 of C times su 2 X to the dual
group that's essentially what guy out to
and I did accept that we took mammal
more visit from poly one of C to be
trivial but locally it's trivial anyway
but
global you can twist by the symmetries
and do what I've just said the way su 2x
comes in here is rather interesting
something happens that at least to me
was a surprise
so Hitchin did not actually write down
noms equations but he mentioned them
when he talked about noms treatment of
monocles so a surprise to me is that
these equations have a specialization
that gives noms equations and they have
a polar solution that involves an
arbitrary choice of homomorphism from su
2 to the gauge group and that polar
solution has had lots of applications
and in different areas so to define a
boundary condition on sigma 1s that it
should have the polar behavior just
described and this type of boundary
condition is also important for Covino
phonology the rest of the boundary
condition is trivial the assembly
extends the chosen homomorphism from su
2 to the dual group to a homomorphism
from PI 1 of C times SQ 2 to the
complexification of the dual group by
setting to 0 in the Boundary fields
don't commute with the pole and ik
waiting the other fields to any local
system once a valued in the comm units
of the image of su 2 I guess that's what
I have to tell you today
thank you very much for the beautiful
talk are there any questions um I wanted
to ask you about this SEO to action
again so they said there are two
different as you tools yes so one of
them you're saying is when manifest self
as a kind of art or circle yes and has
to do so it's not really geometrical for
example one of the generators say the
kind of cart and generator response to
the common logical grading yes what
about the other suit is it one we could
see geometrically while in a trance
lecture we explained a section of the
kitchen vibration which actually is an
apron and one way to get that section
here would have involved embedding the
NAM Paul not an su 2x but in the future
why so I don't claim this is a complete
answer your question but that's an
example of what you can do you
interesting why using su 2 why right but
saying in the context of this T of G
theory that you talked about is it true
that one of the issued tools is realized
more geometrically than the other well
it depends on the description there's a
mirror symmetry between five
descriptions
I didn't have time to explain it
properly let's go back to the quiver so
but I'm going back to the quiz where I'm
taking G to be of type a there actually
are also Quivers of type B C and D but I
think my circles and squares are a
little bit better here so physicists
associate to this quiver a three
dimensional gauge theory which has both
the Higgs and a Coulomb branch but the
definition of the eggs branch is
familiar to mathematicians which is why
you say it's more geometrical and the
description of the Coulomb branch is the
kind of thing that people in my line of
work have a lot of fun with because it
involves the subtle quantum properties
so in that sense your statement is right
the mirrors there's a mirror symmetry
that exchanges the two branches this
particular Quivers actually
self mirror so here t.t of a n minus one
is completely symmetrical between su to
accent ask you to why in the sense that
it can be realized in two different ways
from this quiver and the two
descriptions are related by the exchange
of the two su dues so for instance if we
were to take a one the N one theory
right so you mentioned that that if you
look at the space of a cure it's going
to have two copies of the new plant cone
right yes
so the a one example was actually the I
think the very first example of
inchaallah gator inside work it's
described by that simple quiver which
they argued to be self mirror and part
of the argument was to precisely show
that the moduli space was self mirror it
was two intersecting a1 singularities
but where do we expect to see the SU
tools in this case say you have just two
two important cones right and they are
connected at the origin
yes that's the method's precise
description oh that's the description of
the moduli space of course if you you
have made the question can we declare
but an example what you could be asking
is is there something on which both as
teachers act non-traveling that's right
so for hot for groups of higher rank
there's a simple-minded answer which is
that there are lower straddle in which
both groups act but I don't think that's
the right way to go answering you the
right answer is to tell you the
following this isn't just a singular
space it's a family of vacuum in a
quantum field theory and there's a lot
we should say about the quantum field
theory at any points the most
interesting point is the one at the
origin and if you're living at the
origin it's a super conformal field
theory with all kinds of operators many
of which will transform under both as
u2's but anyway even the ones that
transform under one ask you to or
another their correlation functions will
not factorize right so in other words
the reaction of the groups is expected
not on the space but on the principle in
quantum field theory which is much more
complex than just the moduli space
within yes because you think Euler it's
mostly but partly because of singularity
the important the signal art is an
important part is false in general if
you're at a smooth part
if you're an experimentalist you usually
want to know what happens at long
distances because that's what you can
measure and also a lot of complications
go away after all understanding what
happens at short distances is usually
described as trying to understand the
laws of nature
so at CERN they build an accelerator and
try to make measurements at short
distances but it's hard to get to
shorter and shorter distances whether we
like it or not anything we measure is
usually a bigger distances than
something else so that's why I said at
the beginning that going to long
distances is more or less the universal
problem of physics but for
mathematicians and geometric Langlands
there's no distance but that actually
means you're at long distances I know
you don't think about if I worry but
take it from me now at a smooth point
going to long distances can be
adequately described by the classical
geometry but at a singular point it
cannot be and the singular points are
the most interesting ones as you might
surmise
for this class of examples orange and
it's more in local I can't learn
something I can understand instantly but
there might well be a connection I think
it's safe to say that this is a mirror
symmetry bit it's at the Bristol - in
some sense but yes if we push all the
analogies all the way that that should
be connected I didn't know what I don't
actually know what's interesting to do
with a second as you do the example I
gave Edward when he asked in a few
similar examples all I thought of that
you can do that's interesting but maybe
if I knew more about what you're saying
one would think of something else and
you have a questions yes well in general
for any G the top strata I actually
assumed by France because I was running
all the time but in general for any je
the top stratum the two tops tried are
the two an opening cones
I wrote it here so the top strata are
one they'll put in comm times the apex
in the other cone or the apex and the
first times the second I'll put in
counter those are top strata in the
sense that but they're topped with
business as you either sq to X or s qy
excellent as much as possible and each
of these strata are special because one
of the SE two doesn't act on it then
you've got lower strata which are
products of orbits and except for a n by
2 and I did not completely determine
which pairs of orbits come in for a n
there's a long on duality between orbits
that exchanges flips a young tableau any
so that duality comes in here but I
don't really know what happens for other
groups any other questions there isn't
well they see I wrote this is a very
long paper with Gratzer woman physics I
refer to it before a strategy of
boundary conditions in 2008 so it hasn't
well there isn't any written reference
where one tried to digest it for
mathematicians a small part of West
Plains is in the talk I gave which has
the title the title I remember exactly
but has Nam and Bogomolny in the title
let's think